I'll suck it I'll suck it twice to make
sure bro I lost his
M you know what this
enough twice to make sure it's crazy
yeah I'd go for each
[Music]
Fang dang okay guys Girls welcome back
indeed um so we got a very special one
to today highly requested so as you guys
know when we have a guest in the studio
I like to J I like to J sheett it so if
you don't know J sh allows to do a
massive introduction to everyone that he
has uh come on his show because he wants
it's one of them situations where a lot
of time people don't have the
opportunity to say how they truly feel
about someone and the best qualities of
someone um and when you do it actually
reminds you what a good person that
person is facts so obviously these
people here we haven't spent much time
with them at all
but the world knows them the world knows
them the world knows them man standing
on the shoulders of giants without these
two there'll probably be no us two fact
setting the the the president setting
the standard setting the president and
standards from Duos bro before these man
there was just ant and deck and that was
it fact an de that was Z fact that's
true yeah true couple lightskinn dark
SKS we would never would have made it we
wouldn't have survived we would we would
have survived the streets would ate us
wild
course um so what we want to do is have
a big big big warm welcome to the very
wellestablished the very worldwide loved
chunks and Philly guys for today
y that's incredible guy yeah I feel like
I've done like business you guys do do
BU putting years standing on business
standing on real business years has been
years of course but it's just like it's
nuts man really do appreciate
introduction man thank you guys thank
you man yeah all glory to God the live
and world can't playing Health you get
me so I'm good man yeah Echo what he
said Same Old breathing you know what I
mean breathing that's yeah that is
enough that's enough complain facts cool
we like as you said we like to start the
show off with a little ice breaker
little roast little roast the C baby
that's not even an ice bre I should
straight this yeah so yeah yeah before
we start it's not from us it's not from
us it's not from us you have agreed to
the ones that are
in obviously yeah this
yeah yeah iPad you see they got two
iPads not for
one so right just like we've got like
five each yeah yeah five
five water off a duck's back minor you
man you man will firm these ones pause
um right
so I'm I'm fizzy I'm going cook Philly
and then you're going to cook chunks
right chunks all right who's going first
you go you start you start all right
cool this was a bit
dread man said yeah Philly has a room
temp
IQ room temp lukewarm wait who laughed
in the
back room
10 say that's you know that's Max 21
he the roast
is I need to do the IQ test can't mine's
Loy
roomy IQ do you know what that means
you're Max 21 like IQ dumb you that's
the highest you get like I got 119 the
other day yeah but I want a proper test
my life are you sick I paid for it is it
yeah respect my think
119 no mine what you see my first one
I'm happy with I know I'm not the
brightest I'm a creative man but on the
box I already know what they're going to
get me for it's either a weight
situation or a hairline s so go on do T
blood all right go on
go charge it you know what charge it
you know self-deprecation yeah
interrogation the best way man say play
one bounce One Touch say that you know
you used to play one bounce one touch
you L you have to stand against the wall
yeah and you're like do it man just do
it just do get over with all right all
right bet every time chunks hears Philly
name his brain automatically completes
it with cheese steak Yeah that's a very
good one that's a very good one that's
in very good that's inventive that's a
violation why you happy about why you
happy about it this
that one's mental you know he hey chill
chill you
know I'll be honest with you very
creative I think they made
it down I can show you the T I show you
the Fred we ask our fans they some
stupid ones where you guys actually
thinking demographic break that down so
what that meant was chill chill chill
chill there's more there's more let's
just move when you think about a
Munch fair enough fair
enough yeah
you that's yeah all right right all
right this one's light as
well Philly looks like one of them
hyenas that used to follow scar around
in The Lion
[Music]
[Laughter]
King that's dread I remember one of my
eyes were droo yeah one of them yeah one
of them yes one of them was clapped I
don't think it's the clap one yeah no is
is it's him it's him it's the one that's
the one bro it's that particular one you
told me I'm handsome no but it just
obviously scar you you know what I mean
you're behind doing like this Joke Man D
it up your eyes that's you bro yeah
let's go chunks is one
though chunks is the type of guy to
sweat Pepsi Max yeah that's
good the type of guy the type of guy to
sweat Pepsi Ma you could catch it in the
car later bro
ah and is it still fizzy as well yeah
flat has to be it's sweat man has to be
a young flat one I don't mind I might
have to start testing that after I play
football or something here's a question
have you ever had a guest that doesn't
take these well um no actually I'm glad
you know no no no we haven't we haven't
we haven't but same time we would never
invite a guest who couldn't take it well
yeah I hear that yeah yeah Joyce one was
looking techy yeah at first is it yeah
but she was like I we tried to go on Joy
is it cuz some of them were tough we
tried to go light on her and then she
was like [__] you're not going light on
us right no these no
no might be the
the hard to to that bet all right cool
this one says ask Philly what s time 7
49 my guy my guy come on no man
shouldn't be that excited I'll be honest
with you that's his favorite one he
like that's his favorite one no do you
know what it is that person must watch
okay what's 9 * 9 I was going to say
what's 9 * 9 that's 84 strug 81 trying
to say I'm in and around the areas get
I'm in the Box you land land yeah fair
play fair play fair play chance I said
84 I'm not going to lie that's at 84
chunks runs like someone's Auntie who
missed the
bus you're running for it's horror no
it's not right we have to understand
obviously where I've been just big my
whole life gate is
it's it's not loose but obviously over
time we hope we pray
God but one thing I will say is that
your Fitness is
incredible bro he can do a 90 minutes
match nonstop running I could do I could
do the techniques funny come on funny
Techni and you like that one too much I
didn't
exp I do 5Ks light work in 25 minutes he
embra my fitness is gash it yeah gash so
cool you just W for no reason Lally
reason just athetic little aesthetic
yeah aesthetic yeah good hairline no
reason can't run J all right we should
have come in our home yeah I
know on these there'll be time there's
time in future right this is the last
one Philly looks like he eats the
chewing gum underneath desks just a
nasty
SC scat you you just do that you just
scrape him putting him out you know is
it does look like that
mut yeah just a little
chewish he might have got underneath on
that he said I didn't even
scrap and he wants the old ones one from
2011 theer the better you know
hear come on yeah harder the better
that's my brother though scho School my
Brother harder the better man that's his
new name Now teach their
own that's it that's really that's it
get me out free last one for my family
though chunks
yes God man you like that one yeah I
love that one all right chunks looks
like he pay his Barber to keep quiet Oh
that's oh yeah that's a VI that's bear
fibers when they get the card on man you
know about the card come on boys we've
been there why everyone know about it
huh we've been there we've been there
stand I'm a growing man but I'm Not
Afraid not standard though if your the
is standard now but I'm living cuz I I
need me and my bar have beef every week
cuz I need to wash my head immediately
and coming out shower just like put
black Twi yeah little go you
see emo yeah like yeah support Metallica
in I was it prior is it same same yeah
so then just do do after and then we're
good all right little rag situation Fair
no can't lie uh the worst one today was
the Pepsi Max yeah Pepsi Max say less
pep was a v that was violation you
me come on brother man brother we've
been on YouTube for eight years now n
years I've seen the worst comments this
is light there you go you know what my
favorite comment was yeah so we done
this something similar on Pro direct
yeah when we called it it was a show
called
mean comments mean comments Miss with
you on Pro direct um and then they said
chunks and Philly walking together look
like the number 10 I seen that one do
you know how crazy that one it took what
was funny about that clip was the
realization that if I'm one
he yeah that one I couldn't sleep for
two weeks they they they peppered me
with that one but I was like you the
amount of people that sent this one in
you've probably read it before we love
that one we love it someone to be fair
someone re and said because of your
weight loss it's now you guys are
looking like 11 11 someone said I saw
someone that's I saw someone said it
looks like a Merc
Twix
what that's like why is your thing got a
bit more yeah
g
yo my why is your te got bit more G but
there's nothing wrong with that
whaty on chat to be nice and proper and
nice the [__] we can't say we have a
good
girl
oh
God I'm not asking you to pre it you
know I mean you know I cled yeah you
know this new y thing and pause it's
gone it's out of control now I love it I
wouldn't change it for the world I love
it I think it's hilarious man n man I'm
I fil I fil I fil with har Pano was it
your your video yeah we're filming and
literally we stopped the video every 5
Seconds whoa whoa I said bro can we talk
then can we have a conversation to the
point I to go out boys that's enough
we've got enough like like the whole
just we went overboard we really went
over yeah we lost it that man will ask
for a for quiet why is man asking Mano
just got stupid bro it got stupid yeah
sometimes bro sometimes they get mad we
got one of our boys uh he's he's on it
relentlessly I can't man I can't them I
just want to speak I love it I love it
what did he say what did you say the
other day bro we was playing table
tennis and you said something crazy I
can't you said something like bro you
can hit it from the back or you want I'm
not flinching that's no okay no that one
no that one's wrong
that to be fair I remember one of the
braest ones I did say but it didn't it
didn't I did it didn't uh clock to me
until afterwards we were at dinner all
of us were at dinner all of our boys and
R tied his hair to the back I was like
oh is that all yours it looks big and I
I was so oblivious why you
smiling that's the first time I heard of
that bro
what just talking hear from the back I
Ain flinching that's the wi you can hear
from you want ain't
flinching I was probably locked in I
dropped my B immediately like what's
going on G all right bet so I has been
broken um as you said before obviously
it's an honor to have you guys here a
massive pleasure facts um so we just
wanted to have like this B just open
chat really um
one of the main things that I've noticed
about you guys that I don't think many
people really really clock is that you
guys as far as I know I've never seen
anyone else do it you guys have managed
to find yourself in a situation where
you obviously started off as like
separate uh content creators then you
had like a stint where it was just you
two all the time from from a viewer's
perspective every shoot you you you and
you became like this like I said earlier
like iconic deal like the UK Duo for
like a span of years and over the last
couple years you've again successfully
managed to trans transition out of it
and then still just dip in out in out
and everyone's just happy with however
you do it would you say is there any
like intent behind that or is it all
just focused on what you want to do when
you want to do it great question brother
genuinely um that's amazing no no it is
because I've always thought about this
but we've never had a conversation about
this genuinely bro it was a thing where
um obviously I started by myself being a
fan of pH I know people know the story
already I started myself being a fan of
Philly wanted to just make one video
with them realized just off of that one
video that the the vibe unmatch bro the
chemistry was there and the better mind
he wasn't my friend I didn't know who he
was and from that we kind of realized we
have to do more and more stuff together
but what we realized is we started to
get more of Attraction get more views
when we made videos together so we kind
of thought let's just ride the wave and
see how this goes cuz it's like we
enjoyed each other's company we enjoy
making videos with each other and most
importantly we were like very good
friends you know so that was the
beginning and I think what we realized
after time is like we were doing maybe
too much together potentially cuz
obviously we realized that we came in as
separate entities so we kind of like
maybe we back back away a little bit and
start doing our own things and focus on
our own like graft almost but then what
we ended up doing was taking too much of
a step where I now signed for other
brands which is obviously rivaling his
Brands and it's kind of like okay well
we can't even work with each other
because all the brands that we work with
are like kind of just rivaling each
other you know so then they got to that
and then we kind of sat down and
realized that we don't even work with
each other anymore so we thought you
know missing each other deep yeah
generally man like we'd randomly phone
each other and go bro I miss you
obviously where he's like booked like
last month I had two days off like my
calendar's boomed in I had three shoots
before this one here today you get what
I'm saying so like all glory to God I'm
so grateful but because of that I don't
get to spend time with him no more do
you get what I'm saying and the time
that we did spend it was on set and even
though it was on set we didn't take that
for granted cuz I'm in's presence you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah so yeah
um he'd be calling me randomly and vice
versa and I just be like bro I miss you
and he and then I remember the first
time he saw me off the why he was B Gas
he was like hey it's good to see I'm
talking about the month two
months yeah in mind we now there's times
where like in a two month span out of 60
days man see him 47 days stay his house
yeah so that kind of vibe and then it's
gone from a year of that to then a year
maybe even two of maybe a man once every
two months like you know what I mean so
it's kind of it's kind of weird you know
what I mean and obviously that's when we
kind of got to the phone with each other
and said you know we've always wanted to
start a podcast so why don't we just
finally do what we've always wanted to
start and plus excuse to see each other
more and maybe within the last two
months I've seen them like 15 20 days
and nice happy more Maness but it's very
nice to see and but and I realize why I
I like not seeing him because he's very
annoying as well like that's why no all
my friends say that about
me but I do on purpose I get a little
annoying people yeah I know you mean I
get I ring him like annoy him I just my
thing was when I didn't see him as much
tell him tell him tell him I'll be like
I'll ring him and I'll go yo remember me
like I'm that guy that used to film with
like me and you I con like we was the
guys remember what do you want bro the
first time I was laughing bro this is 15
20 times you know I mean like the same
oh snap what you saying bro I'm like
what do you want bro you know I mean I
would change it for the world though
what would you say what would you say
his annoying traitors then he's lazy oh
is he yeah like but disgusting lazy like
in what sense like he'll be in the crib
and he's sending one of the mandom or me
to go get him a drink
[Laughter]
downstairs he would send man because
don't get me wrong obviously he's asking
nicely he's not yo go get me a drink but
us as his friends cuz we love him so
much we just accept how lazy he is you
have to understand obviously I grew up
in the house with darkest that was my
little cousin right all I used to do was
give him an extra pound and say yo grab
this oh man so I just got used to it and
then obviously now it's completely
changed now to get up
myself to be fair that's probably
similar traits between us two is it yeah
I'm the more annoying one for sure and
he's [__]
lazy this guy yeah if he's ever tired or
hungry you're not getting anything done
bro we could be bro there times we been
like bro half an hour late for a shoot
and we're in the car like bombing it and
he's like bro we're stopping to get
sandwich I'm like big man we're not
stopping for nothing bro like we're late
and he's like I promise you now I'm
charging a whole shoot if I don't get
sandwich right now your energy no your
worth though I I won't be able to give
them my full best you want or not yeah
do you want F had or not you know that
that's that's when me and chunks changed
the game cuz like at early in obviously
we're new to like all the brandle world
is it and I remember they would try to
give man a sandwich and I'm like ra I've
been doing yeah man for 3 hours you want
to give man a
sandwich he he got
angry remember that time when he when
they bought pizza lost my mind I said
cheese and bread for a lunch I I still
remember that I was in and the chicks
you know what I mean I need something
proper but that's just because generally
I don't like pizza pizza for someone
else is actually I got
gu it's a
normal yeah I refuse to have a bit of
bread for my lunch knowing that I've
given you like the best version of me on
camera like I deserve to have a good
lunch yeah facts bro
100% That's funny though man Jesus um
one thing I wanted to ask you obviously
you guys are both creatives in the space
and you both have delved obviously not
you anymore but you've delve both delved
into music world no I miss their music
with him though was there would you say
is there or was there a difference in
these industries the music world and the
creative industry H I've got something
to say about that yeah with with um the
entertainment industry obviously uh
thank God we kind of got to like the top
of the game I feel like in the UK when
you're thinking about entertainment and
YouTubers and influencers you're
thinking about chunks and Philly but
with the music louder say that
louder 20 2018 19 20 we were doing our
thing you know what I mean but then what
happened when we transitioned into the
music scene it's like there was no
ratings for the Mand them so we thought
no but no okay wait wait there was but
not from people within music you get
what I'm saying we charted 19 with and
26 with both of our songs like
independent that's mad you I'm saying
the scene was yeah like I just thought
it was easy some just shout ra yo jump
in the collab uh yeah bro just come up B
and I look at him thinking W what they
don't Artic you say brother dming me to
your new to your new thing like it kind
of got weird you know what I mean so it
was like but obviously what I've
realized over time it's like I can't
expect anything from anybody and
generally like it's that sense of maybe
that small sense of naivity and
entitlement I had as a as a younger
where I thought someone would do
something for me because why not you
know what I mean but like I've realized
now that life it doesn't work like that
but it just that was the big shock I
think maybe jumping into the scene
realizing that whoo like nobody's
actually going to help man you get it so
that was that was a big surprise but
obviously I don't I don't I don't hold
it against anybody you know what I mean
cuz obviously as we got bigger and
bigger and bigger that's when the
rappers that we were messaging start
messaging back saying yo did you want to
yeah and to also add to what you said
about like it being hard it was the
transition is hard cuz you have to earn
your
stripes like my thing was I need you to
rate me as to why you're doing the
Rhythm okay like so like and the first
time I got ratings and the first rapper
that gave me that was Chip you get what
I'm saying like when I went to the boof
of Chip like I take long to write I'm
talking weeks two weeks like the
dyslexia is real it's not a joke what
you see in them videos you know I take
long and it was so easy of him cuz he's
smart so if I have an idea I've got a
Bary he'll be like a and you know what
I'm saying it was sick doing music
chunks um but yeah when I got on a booth
of Chip I was like yo like Hook was
scaring on you was like no big man I
heard you on the Melodies man you got
that you get me like he really like gave
me a mad confidence boost and that's
when I realized ra I've been accepted if
the M if one of the best pens in the UK
has accepted me then I'm in like I'm
good you know what I'm saying P You're
sorted man yeah that's sick man as well
I can imagine as well like with what
you're saying in terms of the difference
in people in the industry like not
showing love and not rating and stuff
like that I think especially cuz the way
from our experience as well like the way
YouTube and like content creating works
is this that like numbers is everything
there's no excuses because it's all
public opinion like you're not like just
getting boosted obviously there's
certain examples where someone makes
friends with a famous group and then
they get boosted themselves but for the
most part you everyone started from zero
and then grinded up whereas like again
like music is not like that it's a very
like artistic thing and like um if you
could have a tune that slaps but like it
can get buried no one's finding it and
stuff like that so I can imagine they're
very precious about their industry
whereas like again content creation if a
thing says a million Subs it says a
million subs and nothing you can tell me
so like no one I don't need you you
don't need me no one needs anyone so
it's just about Vibes and enjoyment and
then everyone just collabing all the
sake for the sake and for the fun of it
um and there's no there's no one real to
hide like there's no one in the YouTube
space that's like they're just not
showing me love I'm this I'm like I'm
the sickest YouTuber going and they one
show me love cuz it's like well show me
the subs show me the numbers yeah if
you're sick then the subs will do it
yeah um but apparently yeah for
obviously for music reason that's that's
the same you can be the sickest pen in
in the world and no one even knows who
you are that's mad isn't it like I've
always said that you know like I've like
every song I was deep in it the other
day I taed in my name in the official
charts every song I've released on the
face of this Earth is charted you know
how mad that is that's disgusting that's
incredible but there's man that are 10
times better than me musically but won't
achieve what I have that's mad is it bit
unfair as
well yeah man it's so unfair like even
like half of my friends are better than
me and I'm just like steep like yeah but
you also paved your way in a different
way to then step into another Lane like
that's how people that's how people do
their things sometimes a lot of what um
for example The Rock wrestler all his
life acting now pretty much all his life
you like that for honest you know I mean
if we're comparing him to like I'm
talking the Robert daos and and the
Leonardo DiCaprio you know what I'm
trying to say like on their levels get
paid the same and they have to respect
it you have to rate it bro because I'm
not having man sit on my face for 10
years in a
so that I can do something else you mean
so like what he's done the things he
sacrificed the things he put his body
through um for all those years he should
be able to just step like give me give
me the biggest he put in a graft didn't
he did same way you guys put in the
graft and then music is like a a lighter
step to take it's not a harder grind
even though it's still a hard grind it's
just not that hard you know cuz you
already got the space you got the
acquisition and everything we would have
been gone if we carried
on talk man you want to know good F ch
the first dat so like it like how it
works you do pre-sell in it before like
songs come out we had a song called Hold
yeah and then that day that we done the
pre-s for holds like everyone does their
pre-s you know we had more SS than Miley
saris and Justin Bieber Little Mix
blood still remember when we got the
message in the group chat Philly lost
his
mind mix at the time do you know how mad
that is say l rocking us man hard we're
just in general our suppor is that yeah
even now still though like even now
still man get mad love bro and so do you
like we're so blessed blessed bro to man
that's sick man um so the only other
question I wanted to ask was back to
like content obviously you guys do so
much like branded work and stuff like
that now and obviously on top of that
you've been in the the game for a minute
like what we've always said to ourselves
that we just we want to put ourselves in
a position where we can just do this
until we wake up one day and be like I
actually can't bother it I don't want to
do it anymore and then we're in a
position where like I don't never have
to to do it again I don't ever want to
be in a position where I'm doing this
when I don't want to um so for like you
two individually what is it that like
especially for your own channels what is
it that motivates you to ever do a video
on your own
channel um on my own channel I think it
would be um the fact that I've got I
actually took it in recently obious I've
only started uploading consistently
again for the last three months two and
a half months but it was like sitting
home and thinking all right I'm about to
hit 3 million subscribers and I haven't
uploaded consistently in maybe 3 years
like when I when I stopped uploading
consist I had 600k subscribers so I was
like I've gained 2.4 from all the brand
stuff I've done and all this bet squ
stuff I've done and I was like I kind of
felt bad that I've got all these fans
and subscribers waiting to for an upload
and I kind of had that passion again for
Content creation after filming with with
beta Squad again so that was the reason
I thought you know there's people there
that want to watch the videos and ever
since I've started uploading again the
views have been decent and stuff so that
was my drive and obviously I started off
by being a YouTuber in 2015 and like I
always thought to myself how would I
look at my my 18-year-old self and how
would my 19-year-old self look at me now
thinking you got what you wanted and you
just stopped like what the hell like
I've always wanted to hit 1 million
subscribers so once I hit I think maybe
that kind of just made me tail off and
that's where I get the lazy allegations
and stuff you know because before that 1
million subscribers I think I was grind
the hardest working person out of all my
friends guaranteed they they V for me as
well but after maybe when I hit targets
I'm just kind of like well I've done it
now you know and I think that's why
we're trying to just create like a whole
crazy Dynasty with the beta Squad stuff
so I think I maybe too focused on that
but now I've kind of pull back in and
I'm back on my channel back uploading
again man I'm enjoying it really loving
it same for me you know um I just deeped
I'm doing so much on other people's
channels like I can say with chest I am
the reason foot Asylum got all them
subscribers I they called me first that
was the first ever one to do videos then
I called chunks then they called Harry
do you get what I'm saying then they
called everyone else so when I deep it
obviously not just me take that of a
pcture so everyone watching listen but
obviously everyone involved everyone has
taken part in the videos I've got them
that two point whatever but when I deep
it I'm like the blueprint do you get
what I'm saying and then um I deeped I'm
like how is it that they've had their
Channel less time than me and they've
got more subscribers than me and that
was it bro I was like all right cool
it's time like it's clear to obviously
again I'm not saying I got all of them
subscribers but I I definitely a massive
hope in that and then that's when I
realized yeah man it's time to start
uploading consistently again like now
the problem I do have is I don't know
what video to release this week I got
I'm yeah and similar to chunks in that
same ASP like there's so many content
creators that would love to be in my
position and I'm if I can say taking a
piss to a certain extent cuz I'm not
working as hard as I know I can um so
yeah that's why I'm active on absolutely
everything right now stream every day
Tik Tok Snap I've noticed YouTu say see
you guys a lot every angle like there's
nothing even Facebook I'm uploading
every day I'm not lacking on no
Department right now speaking on snap I
remember there was a time you used to
post this was I'm talking years ago the
park on the running in a park running in
a park and then you used to live with a
guy used to girl CP Charles I what a guy
in it those two used to sweep the life
out of you I remember that was my first
ever introduction to you
actually the park one one of my
girlfriend at time sent me this see this
that's when I learned about brands of
you had a brandle with NHS yeah and if
you didn't know get to know Brands go
through everything you do yeah they look
up all your videos they PR your
engagement what your audience is like so
anyway I shot this video now for NHS all
good and gravy I'm like bof w getting
paid my first that was my first like
brandle and then they've come back
saying yeah we're not going to release
the content don't worry you'll still get
paid for your time but we've seen like
the content that you do and it doesn't
match with and it makes sense it's the
NHS man's talking about yeah man cled it
out carrots were dead like you get what
I'm saying so I understood but that's
when I understood like wow I need to
form a brand this is deep and and pleas
in the hood like I need to build
something like a slogan let me get a
nice logo like let me watch the things
that I do say I don't want to offend no
one you got I'm saying so okay yeah I'm
kind of glad I did those videos one
because it made me uh known and relevant
and at the same time I'm glad that I'm
made those videos in that way because it
taught me what it is to be a brand you
know what I mean makes perfect sense I
hear you um question for the both of you
outside of like the creative world
obviously you're both into your football
I know you go to Arsenal games quite a
bit and what was it like to um playing
the first like soccer a charity
match in front of like thousands and
thousands and thousands and no so wa
mine wasn't in front of I don't mind
during Co our first one was in Co so
this was empty I took it l but he's done
two or three since then three since then
and all of them have been in pack
Stadium yeah but not in general just
forget about the pack stadiums
me and for Philly obviously we told the
story before Philly originally got
called for soccer a first by himself
okay uh they didn't have no mention of
my name in there it was literally old
Phils we wanted to come cuz I think the
person that invited him his son or his
daughter or her daughter her son was a
big fan of Philly and um Philly told me
about the opportunity and I was like bro
I've been watching soc for years like
I've been watching this you know
everyone knows what it is you know um
and obviously Philly obviously like I've
been saying the kind of person he is he
was like if you want to play I'll get
you involved I was like how you going to
get me involved in an ITV thing you me
and he just basically emailed him saying
um I want chunks to play and me and him
will share minutes and he didn't he
didn't have to do that you know so I C
my
yeah but then luckily obviously the
woman was like um oh yeah now my my son
or daughter knows who he is too like
yeah might as well get him get him along
you know what I mean so thankfully they
accepted me to come down as well and
when me and Philly came down I still
remember in the hotel and and we was
just kind of look at each other like all
right so we're going to go out here and
no one's going to know us I said cuz we
obvious you got you got like footballers
and you got comedians we just like knew
no one's going to know us just I mean me
knew just stick to ourselves and we're
good we should be all right you know
what I mean we're gas bro you know what
I mean this is nuts and obviously like
like you said I'm a big football fan so
there's footballers that I grew up
watching so obviously now we've looked
at the time and they said all right cool
so we have to be to that place at let's
say 3:00 p.m. we're like all right cool
let's not get it at 3 that's going to
look excited you know mean and plus no
one will be there at 3 so we're like
cool we'll just chill I think maybe 10
three like cool let's get there we're
walking towards the little pitch now
everyone's there and they're like CH
Philly come on and we're waiting for you
and I [__] talking ke yeah like and we
were like oh no we can't be the the
latest ones so we coming in and they
just started to take the piss out of us
saying you have to run the whole place
and we're just I mean laughing but as
we're going we just trying to introduce
ourselves and was just like oh hi my
name is Chunks and like what you got
this is what we do every before they
even introduced our St they're like what
we know you like our kids love your
videos and stuff furthermore can we get
pictures and this is like the John
Terry's the Patty mcginness John Bishops
and these are people that just grew up
watching and then the the biggest one
obviously we get to the middle now Sam
allad and Wayne Rooney's there right and
obviously I'm thinking in my head Wayne
Rooney even like the headaches he calls
my team Arsenal so I just don't like
this BR even staring at him but then
obviously you know he just goes to
Philly after and goes oh yeah um you got
that show on on BBC um hot property I'm
a big fan me and my M watches it blah
blah blah and as he's saying it bear
mind it's not my show bro this Philly
thing but I'm I'm
like I can't control it and obviously
new V just trying to like like it's
nothing when you when when you're when
you're with your Breen and you do these
ones
yeah is talking my so obviously as
Wayne's talking now you just me and pH
just yeah and obviously now as he's turn
around and cut true we've just gone
I so and then he's like bro did you hear
him I was like what do you mean did you
I was next to you we just couldn't
believe it bro and obviously further
more just playing playing playing and
all of a sudden like Philly scoring a
goal
like generally like we were in a
simulation that week like Sim to the
point like we would just kept having
crazy experiences and to share that
moment with my my brother um probably
the probably one of the best moments in
my whole life if I'm honest man until
today like I've done I've done three
more after that but nothing hit that the
first one if I'm honest man genuinely
like best experience ever man genuinely
sick all guys let's take a quick break
let's let's take a break from the
shenanigans to help you guys out so
fellas listen close can you smell the
pumpkin spice in the air obviously of
course you can if you haven't heard it's
fresh face full and nobody else can give
your face the love it needs other than
your friends at manscaped the folks who
Chang below your belt are here to help
with their brand new handyman electric
face shaver let's go right listen up
this is designed to give your face that
smooth finish without the mess of a wet
shave it's the perfect tool for men with
all with all beard length with all Bard
links M fages myself God forbid Ellis
God forbid whether you're lining up your
neckline or taking it all off for that
Autumn Breeze make sure to join the 9
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped with our exclusive offer all
you need to do is head over to
manscape.com and use the code SN CR
November Golf and that's going to give
you 20% off plus free shipping don't be
a bad apple this year choose manscapes
[__] hell that's so sick uh right
we're going to jump to a game yeah yeah
yeah all cool so we got the most
anticipated segment of the show to come
let's go what the fans have all been
waiting for it's the best friends
[Applause]
quiz I'm not even worried I'm I'm going
to do well he's going to do sure swear
I'm worried I think I'll do it right I'm
sure we got this I think we'll patent it
yeah they don't know the questions yeah
no no nobody know nobody knows question
no bi you got your white balls next to
you your pens you got your wipes
everything are WR Point listen bro you
know me man yeah come on man SL so yeah
how it's going to work is uh REM will
ask either Philly a question you both
have to write the same answer down
obviously show your white balls at the
end after that same vice versa he will
ask me a question we have to get same
answers blah blah blah highest winner
highest points wins highest points is
the best doer in it highest points best
in this is for the crown for did this in
2020 we would have won we each other
every day now he's too rich now chill
out all right talk to us who you going
who's going who's going first so we got
left to the dealer so I ask Philly first
then chunks and then I'll Swit fad to
James James to fuad all right bet cool
come six questions each cool cool all
right so question number one Philly when
is chun's birthday
my brother my brother if W bro you know
how long we've done this [__]
question can I swear by the way yeah
flipping hell bro man don't piss me off
please ready yeah in three two one 21st
verb 21st verb
come don't give my joke man that's right
all right one ZIP say less got a point
all right cool
chunks what is Philly's biggest
fear bro my brother Co man must have
another J I don't know about I'll keep
pushing after this man it's all
good Oh
sha biggest fear what's he scared of he
doesn't like hot chili
stuff all right I don't know don't look
at me thing quick he knows he knows know
fear fear fear it's not trying to cheat
bro
what he heard he heard a clue and then
he's going to try to rewrite it n you
can't do that you can't no no no no
write better bro hand on hot hand on hot
hand on hot all right say less hand on
fear fear you're not scared of hot food
you just don't like it all right I'm
going to just guess [__] I'm not good at
thisal guess your dead you're dead here
just own it bro it's calm I'm not a good
friend that's better is it that's cold
is it I made it B I made it
rather than just putting words it's
boring in
it yeah ready fre two one heights
yeah come on oh my this is my biggest
fair is it yeah of I know
that say less right for
two yeah when it's James's birthday
let's go
I lit just escap
bored oh yeah
just oh my what date of birth yeah date
of birth everything wait what wait why
are you thinking see date of birth yeah
I just panicked for a second you know
you know what year I was born bro I know
I know the year I I trying to give him
cles a yeah yeah see that's like think
about proper extra to yeah yeah a really
a pan why he paniced quickly I know the
thing is I know it but I'm Pani you
written it yeah yeah God Joke Man three
two
one shook me bro I shook myself I I
wouldn't have forgiven you for that I
know you wouldn't have all right stre
wouldn't have everyone's good all right
James
next fuad's on death row for an absolute
mad thing yeah long de last Mill last
you don't know it what's his final
meal final man you man keep on pushing
young little two1 for us this is the duo
here man James and fuu keep it push push
yeah don't try to show him I see
Ang and see me I'll purposely R my like
this yeah cuz you're won oh brother I'm
not even going to lie I don't even know
should I
know oh my God is that what we're doing
on this show is that
bad that's like look I'm asking for a
clue don't say yes or no to that I
didn't him him look at him how about
should I know just cuz you don't know BR
James no if you ain't Bening 100 in kg
your chest is a liar cuz brother you see
your chest 100's light to them say
130 never you see the eye
cl's remember be hum um right last me
think about it bro no all of that no
okay say no
more it's a che love just think about
Ito yeah yeah remember what we had
before [__] my mind's gone blank I'm
just going to write yeah you're just
going to write the right answer it cheat
all right sorry j all right three two
one we bought Ro I put J A you I was
going to write J but I didn't know what
to write it with I got a Munch oxtail is
aite
roast I told you I knew it roast I just
it man's called fad and you think he's
last roast I swear on you I was going to
write J but I didn't know what else with
that's fine bro that's not fine it's not
fine it's not fine it's not fine it's
fine it's
fine it's not fine it's fine bro me your
[__] we run it back we run it back we
run it back all right say l say l you
know about to BR you man love man REM
next one man quick go all right let's go
so next question is for Philly what is
chun's favorite music artist right now
who is chun's favorite music artist
right now that's a difficult
question no I like tro I like dran if
you know me
yeah on yeah ready if you know me ready
3 2
1 what's that tank tank tank is not my
favorite right now oh you love tank
though no that's my favorite of all
[Music]
time he's got voice on him yeah TGT and
all them things
there brother you know stuff bro tank is
my favorite of all time he said right
now you just album I know I know I
know that's a fair one though favorite
all time for you did your best man
that's that's not bad chunks come on in
your opinion H whose goal is
better
yours or Phillies at a time match
Phillies at Sid man yours at soccer
Aid I've never SC I wish I did mine mine
mine at Phil What's called the side game
his one at the Sidman game sorry side
Man game both of them yeah whose goal
was better in your opinion if my
brother's got common and that's sense
I'm ready to sh that was a goal to be
fair I'm ready I remember dirty I
remember that one as well is that on Sky
Sports on their Tik Tok yeah on Tik toks
this is this is this one was dirty as
well I remember come on yeah Sky Sports
looked after the man I remember this I
watch it three two one man ising respect
for my brother come on the go was way
better his one had VI on I'm hearing I
got the best goal in the sidan charity
history yeah it's confirmed by the
Sidman
himself we can't even care about that
that one was a joke but amazing as well
though was top all we needed to put the
I on the cake was Harry to score cuz all
of our brothers scored that day I scored
Niko scored chunk scored but no Harry
say less it 3-1
now was even fair1 yeah you should have
just used your brain and said yeah let's
cheat a bit it's straight right now but
I know my brother's going to say tank
let me put tank you know what I
mean Fair all right all right REM
nervous F head yeah what's James's
favorite meal to
cook that's not even a fair question we
stay cooking stay cooking we stay
cooking favorite meal to cook I don't
even know why I would write myself oh my
God see like all of that I wouldn't even
know right myself that's all like
brother don't worry remember yeah just
remember what we did like last time yeah
remember our Saturday with the boys I C
the lasagna now yeah you see
all thinking in that look at this man
it's ridiculous see and deep me and
Trunks don't think that's my brother
that's actual brother that's je you man
in this for bread real that's yeah
like I want to start what the [__] in
his questions bro whose goal waso is it
your best friend or not fam what's my fa
I don't know what my favorite thing to
cook is so how's he supposed to [__]
know just say something you must know
trust me you must know know I know my
favorite thing to cook is right now all
right do that see what I'm saying
now I I don't know where he cooks like
you are yeah you an ed is it bra see oh
you know what go then James you might as
wellp lips then you're going to do this
then give each other
IUS I didn't even say anything I just
smiled see it smil like BR crazy are we
talking diet no diet
no no diet diet who likes to cook diet
food no diet man this is R you you
you've mered me on this wait for the
questions man like everyone's get the do
a great job brother no you are the
difficulty switches off come on bro
crazy I got you man asking man about my
favorite tunes right now what's that
about man how does he know do he live
with me it's calm you I I doubt you're
going to get but that also lets me know
he's a deeper cook yeah there got option
cuz go and watch watch this for B yeah
let's just both write my favorite thing
to cook no no don't make them I get it
no for B watch if you might get it no no
it just goes to show that he's a deeper
Chef cuz I only cook a certain amount of
Ms ready 3 2 1ass do you see what I'm
saying do you see what I'm saying that
means you're a mad Chef I respect all
right you ready I wrote two so all right
bet 3 two one what did you put I put
Sten shepher pie is braised Ox cheek bro
come on man I'm
doing chill I'm not staying
on I'm letting the SHO I'm Different
it's just a little son of whipped
up I knew you were going to get what I
first of all first of all could have
just said Ox
cheek has to be bra what a young red
wine a man can't slow cook in his own
house oh my days garli of course bro you
have to base it in there you have to
reduce the wine
off high heat you talented man cooking a
a serious skill you know it's my
favorite thing bro it's relaxes me I've
always I've always enjoyed it
damn therapeutic is that is that one of
the go on already get bro come yeah does
FU had believe in
ghosts look how that kind of question
talk about m 3 2 1 what no you don't
since when bro them I don't even know
each other
they don't know each other what would
you have written uh I actually would
have said yes bro you're [__] lying I
would have said yeah I would have said
yes I would have said
yes we had the other day we had an ep
the other day and F had said
that some kind of like extra terrestrial
activity and he was like actually a bit
on the edge of yes I'm swear to God
extraterrestrial and ghosts are two
completely different JNS bro okay fine
that's aliens yes but like there was
something that happened as episode and
you want that's not my fault I I'm not
blaming you bro yeah right yeah yeah
yeah we're charging this round you ask
me what's his favorite meal to cook next
man I'm [__] living bro I'm [__]
living what's the score 41 no no 31 31
31 still 31 31 let me just get a young
little 5 one all right come come I know
my dog knows me Philly this is dumbest
game bro what's trunks's favorite
chocolate
barall if you know you know dreams knows
what me this guy that's the thing about
you though you man like you look I think
it's just cuz it's brand new and um
hands in a minute so when you've been BR
for longer than 11 like I'll show you my
3 2 1 thank you very much guys and
that's the love and
appreciation on pushing and that's and
the fact that we haven't even looked as
is actually spending real time away from
work yeah cuz let me tell you about
these Lots they come work and then they
never see each other until the next one
and that's where you are wrong but keep
pushing I'm not D what are these
questions bro relax man wait just wait
you got an easy one what does he like to
cook you man should be chatting so much
that you should know what your yeah you
see brother yeah I'm just thing is he
got it right face do you got FaceTime
when you at home in it do we FaceTime at
home a FaceTime period FaceTime that on
all that show him man I'm cheing bro
look at this sometimes he's there and
we're not even chatting he's just there
bro
BR give you question so we can bring it
back counsel yeah coming soon coun on my
channel my Chanel that would be a good
video why don't you like each
other I'm lived soon I'm
now next question next question chunks
what is Philly's dream
car I don't know that one to be fair cuz
the thing is I'm not even just saying
the sake of it he's had a lot of cars
that are dreamy which is but I'm going
to guess this
one CU I said I remember wanted it for
the record we would both get that for
each other
yeah huh would you I know his dream card
all right so write it then whilst
they're writing this yeah to show to
show show show yours go on go go on
yours Dre right now my your Dre yeah
yeah yeah
say why why you trying to preum as well
just
wait 3 two
one gwag
gwoke wag yeah cool right what about
James he ain't going to know the
specific but he'll know yeah
the make he'll know the make yeah okay
that count see I'm I'm cuz you always
talk
about you show your little things your
got yeah cool okay three two
one
GG's even the actual yeah they got the
even the
actual hey Dave I'm waiting for you to
text me though so you can give me your
link so I get a cheaper quote ask Martin
de you want the as as well what one in
particular bro the new John the 12 they
they ain't dropped it yet no n I need to
have a look then man I only like SUVs
though 51 by the way you not just Tak
away from the point that it's
51 hey this is L you go uh my pen oh
here here sorry I just got was there all
right let's go next one 51 there's no
point but you keep doing your pushing
all right we got it we got what's
James's favorite anime right now oh yeah
man watch that
you're kidding me bro I think you can B
on this one you can get this if you
don't have this one bro right now right
now
think now 3 2
1 yeah okay okay go the bo go the boys
it had to be it had to be it had to be
that what's the score now to be that or
5 I to give him a no no way
52 jange his question he knows it's a
[__] question as
well that's why he's trying to help you
but if we're being honest bro dream car
and favorite chocolate is a bit nuts CU
there's options the options are there
car is not that nuts no because man
don't have them convos oh you're not to
know it no we don't really I wouldn't I
wouldn't pay to get your favorite
chocolate oh fair fair I I would know
yeah there's no way I'm guessing your
favorite chocolate all right yeah there
you go James I know your Mars bite you
look kind of Mars Bounty bount
disrespectful if they said what's my
worst chocolate
hate coconut I want to know what the
people think if you're watching this on
YouTube comment down below is Bounty lit
yes or no cuz I
think like a t I know
you bro cuz you look like the Snickers
thing oh is it yeah it's crazy shut
the the man like nuts in his mou
crazy ask the question sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry okay okay cool cool who is
celebr who had celebrity crush right now
m easy I know who it is wait what
celebrity crush your celebrity crush
right now spelling doesn't count
spelling doesn't count to show us a
difficult name yeah we'll get a clue out
in a sec oh that was the clue deep tip
who is my celebrity crush right now well
you know who it is bro just be talking
king of little
indirects nuts bro if you man don't have
secret language out that that's your
problem yeah come on come on that's you
you even clocks when you watch the edit
we've been
doing Secret Language Ain secret right
Secret you're not even de from what
doing I'm going to
need I'm going to need you to P up I
even have I ever spoken about my
celebrity crush I
love that every every
test I already know you're going to
write some [__] and it's wrong I'm
just writing you're I'm livid Cameron
Diaz you're crazy don't don't do that
show them 3 2
1 yeah what you right you man Georg
Smith you man's G yeah I can't I think
your team's fake now bro it's Anna Damas
bro what are you talking about you've
said it 100 times she's like the um oh
yeah has she been in anything she like a
Spanish thing she was in James Bond she
was in like um bring her up real quick
cute t yeah I'd love to see her oh she's
beautiful she's been AC quiet a few T
wow she's beautiful still what country
from you bought up like nine times
that's 100 I said that like last year
bro last year no you didn't good stuff
Cuban
never mind I'm n 52 yeah all right
what's Jimmy's question and I want two
more questions left as well n no no this
question no this game's six in total
yeah um so we got
Philly who is Chunks celebrity
crush it's a bit nuts to be fair I
haven't got one but just pick someone
obviously like if you had to pick
someone that's thing or ass
okay the classic one yeah this is why
this is my brother for Life three two
one
Z SP
it it's cute it's cute man said this is
why brother for life and never felt R
never felt tell M no no no I tell you I
her uh work work work work work work me
that music video she right but apart
from that one yeah I can't lie it's a
Lauren London thing man that's a classic
Laur
London even that even with Jonah Hill
recently she was mental I forgot about
that take her in all right all right
chunks so what it 52 still yet it's 52
still God question for chunks what is
Philly's biggest ick this is difficult
now man ah see I told you the difficulty
changes you be Yap y talking L I don't
even know what my biggest is though let
me give it some reason like what's it it
cuz I think mine's too deep what I'm
writing it's just something that really
it's like a petty one is it don't like
from people yeah just we put you off
turns you off bro it's just a nogo for
you oh this is perfect then if you
really know me what don't I go for Ang
like I can't date a girl if she don't
have this believe in God man oh
j i WR ungrateful people oh
jar not g this is people in general no
oh is it ick in people in general ick
your biggest I oh I've heard the
question wrong no I I was I I thought I
has to be it's a Galaxy I has to be
gting why am I watching mandm how you
going from a grown man I hate that he's
lazy but I don't care that's you in it I
thought was a gting [__] man oh well we
heard the question wrong wrong to be
fair wrong
is so we blame the quiz Master cuz the
quiz Master didn't uh questiony it's
cool yeah wrong is wrong is wrong
anyway man's thing ra what did he do
what did you
say man's thing no that's crazy you was
talking about bats and how it feels Yeah
Yeah from behind so you leave me alone
yeah
yeah try it out with me REM all right
REM that's that's crazy in itself man
moaning out the next man's name Mentor
you're grown you know doing that man I
said a ren [__] lips in them my
D I'm getting angry he's trying to
distract
you get back for that one what are
James's siblings names and that's the
thing that you okay no this is deep how
many s do you have three oh you gave him
a clue already they're not going to get
it bro he's tweaking I know all name go
then you know them in it all right a
he's living oh all right ah [__] he's
bro hey hey why you trying to ask for
help man doing this cuz the thing is he
knows that I always get some of them
wrong yeah no that's normal bro that's
normal there's people you
don't listen to him people have been F
about foot Asylum sometimes they even
know that g me one my brother's middle
name is thinking there's no way you're
doing this
well it's cuz I know you brother I'm
trying to say there might be open chair
here coming up know blood
[__] whoa I'm not even taking you
in please bro get it right please please
please even taking him in runs after
that
please like really it a swap seies
but so we allow to take 8 minutes then
there has to be a time limit yeah how
many did you get one bro you know oh you
I've only got one two one I was never
getting that Bro you've Tau me like
twice I always forget are you the oldest
you met them I
know no but I've met chunes and I
couldn't that's I'm terrible with names
I off the right now your your niece and
nephew don't end the names who's the
oldest me sick yeah must be hella proud
of you though you know what we was
having this conv a the other day about
like
um my cuz two of my sbls are half
sibling so they're still really young I
they don't really count but like even
though I'm the oldest I was always like
the like failure like [__] around only
focused on sport never focused on
nothing my brother genius super
successful patented everything so we I
was I was the failure so I know I know
deep down my mom and dad was worried
everyone was worried they must be
buzzing yeah yeah yeah so now they're
guest which which makes me guest I just
like a yeah I'm all right so did we get
a half point or no no no because I'll
tell you why because that question
happened in the best friends quiz part
one what like seven months ago oh no
that was like two years ago regardless
of when it was yeah thank you
good still the same oh he's trying to
say I was trying to help you there damn
siblings ain't changed in two years and
I know you made question more next
question man a what's the score 52 52
okay Jesus Christ fad what are James the
biggest X in
women just oneit just one he in women I
would have loved that one no he
specified he just he just learned from
us so you to to this
junk see stop
it man rubbed out stuff yeah it's nice
yeah cuz he wasn't clear bro yeah three
aggravated is it two
one no this is getting what did you WR
bro Kebab shot Barefoot that's yours
this is getting that's yours
stupid yeah that one's crazy pressure
points that's yours brother how selfish
can you be bro you have that I as well I
do have that I as well but that's your
gotoo next I'm not too fasted on that
one boy you know like if she's with me
what babe your foot hurts like your mad
she's not with you though bro I'm saying
this is Kebab shop like no no shoes in
Kebab shop I promise you she's not with
you yeah you're you're this is end get a
kebab shop for us yeah this is this this
example is like how many questions have
you asked the brosis um so this will be
question number six for feeling out so
we've all done everyone's last one this
is everyone's last round right now so so
you got two points out of six is that
you're saying it's charged now so now
it's just for Vibes yeah so man got two
out of six best friend next some of the
questions bro okay they devastated
Philly yes would chunks rather be
chronically underdressed dressed or
overdressed you know me this my brother
know me BR that's what I like about
brosi cuz like when you do 3 2 one and
get it correct a good feeling and that's
the thing about living and what you want
to do is spend time with one another it
builds a
relationship connection and a build
Brotherhood I was thinking bonds but
that's what you want to do guys so what
what I'll do is I'll get you on this
course that me and chunks do every
Thursday 71 we do a best friend
pram
to it's our show sorup them
sorry them that's go it's true they have
that power but guess what 62 make it all
right chunks would Philly rather have Bo
or smell Bo on everybody
else have b or smell
beo Kan you know me man went that deep
yeah
yay 3 2 1 love you man keep
up you rather be beat off bro you're
telling me I've got a smoke Momsy I
can't hold my knece sis my niece stinks
I want hold my niece and she stinks I
can sort out with a c
se you get what I'm saying but my knee
stinking no but because you see I
thought like you you actually car you
man you rather smell I'd rather smell
people I can violate them instead of me
just smell like [__] yeah but you're the
only da that smells good and that's
that's amazing tra to have you'd get no
but they all stink I don't want
them yeah I hear but I just live life
lessons
lons
Steve love that right next bro it up bro
let's finish this so this is
for so we can only be 64 M make 64
that's nice yeah that's not bad to be
fair that's not bad it's not a bad way
to go bonus round Vibes thises all right
fad yeah would James rather have your um
his least favorite song played on a
constant Loop or never listen to music
again least favorite song constant Loop
you got to deep it that's doing a
dooo in the yard chilling chatting on
the
phone it's a deep question you know
Never Going To Give You Up never going
to all the time
right Banger come on listen let's go
come come come come let's go let's go 63
safe for that 63 safe for that come on
boys I wasn't going to sleep I wasn't
going to sleep tonight all right R come
on man last question give him a tough
one our last one was tough it's a toughy
it's a toughy all right James yeah would
F would Fu had rather only be able to
take 3H hour baths or a 10-second shower
H ready 3 2 1 10 second show yeah 64 M
respect
that's a comeback I'm happy with that
that's a comeback that's a comeback
that's a come back 10 second showers and
no brainer in it hours I'm bur time is
what yeah I'm not going that question is
a bit of a cheat code say for that
though we needed
that need yeah yeah say for that he just
made this that was fun though that was
good man that's having two strangers on
a pillow like
that two
strangers let's go question so we asked
the the team can I just say though
really enjoying myself yeah yeah yeah
man for real I mean that from the bottom
of my heart like I watch you L podcast
to be on it and to feel the same Vibes
that I feel through the screen is sick
oh wow thank you very much bro Jesus
that's throw me off um so we've asked
same way we asked that mad emotional in
it you
know same way um what you do yeah they
the same they do the same way I would
reply to a comment like that how he did
fair I think they did the same in the
gym as well no no way that man's chest
is
mental
I you look you look thank you bro thank
you bro don't blush
yeahp what is it with you and yeah like
what's going on
King be fair we don't k your bks trying
to get me back that's your bag we
actually don't kick
you changing I remember what did you say
for the to see the better Dro love oh
yeah can we have like a big ending well
done guys you are the winner winners are
no we deserve that we're not moving on
with yeah we're waiting right so for
now as it
stands unfortunately unfortunately forun
the best
duo is the two old UTS who had to sleep
together for over a year to get to know
one another facts so big round of
applause fillian chunks for winning this
game I'll take it I'm not take it that's
horrendous why just leave with each
other
but you agreed to it no we know that's
not the trth you said best I can tell
you can tell you're so loser but it's
fine I'm I'm livid anyway moving on so
we did the same way we asked our
audience to roast you guys the same way
we asked our audience to ask you guys
questions but with this we're going to
give you guys the iPad and you guys ask
the questions and you answer it
yourselves nice cool so the first
question is what are your favorite
memories of each other um me we're both
answering yeah yeah yes you say so my
favorite memory is the day I met you
I've never met in my life such a friend
for the first time and hugged chunks the
way that I did it was mad and Cadet was
one of the reasons we met rip Cadet um
but yeah and then the second one would
be soccer raid when we got mad emotional
and deeped how far we got in a in a
hotel room yeah I was going to say that
one to be fair how far you got in the
hotel room how far you got in the hotel
room emal
em
deep now crazy you got in the hotel room
got your emotional that was that that
was that was a joke that was a joke um
it for me CRA say we were in the we were
in the H sound like H we in the hotel
and we were basically reflect on how far
we've come um
since next
question distance you a DOD comparing
distance you a
Dodge comparing distance comparing no
let's fair play fair play boy it's good
that was good comparing distance you
know I don't have no favorite memories
um what was the most difficult shoot you
guys had to do I know what it is he does
another round go on you say what you
think it is you do know what it was we
going 3 two 1 W
Wales going to Wales the worst I'm not
going to violate the brand yeah never
say the but the worst shoot we've ever
done in our existence we had to be there
for 3 days and we were and it felt like
a year we were in
Snowden yeah it was the mountain thing
yeah the mountain times I said and we
wasn't even that far in but it was just
how it was organized Vibes was horrible
the lack of like things that we got
again like like you you are a man that
know your worth and you want to eat
before you shoot so you deliver your
best our hotel room like had sticky
carpet like it was just nuts man nuts
but then again at the same time I kind
of understood stood because we're in the
middle of nowhere yeah but yeah you kind
of should have known I don't know but it
was just it was definitely the worst
Shir so does he read all of them yeah
you can it's the same question for the
no read all of them then read all of
them yeah I
thought uh
biggest there's nothing funny about you
laughing about uh biggest argument
you've ever had between each other yeah
we won't talk about what it was but I
thought I was going to lose my bre oh
yeah yeah
yeah how long ago was this obviously
won't dive into it but how long ago was
this 18 months maybe year and a half
yeah yeah year and a half dam was a big
one one damn and it was even harder for
me in that situation because I was at
fault he done nothing wrong do you get
what I'm saying M what what face did he
for it was even harder for
me I didn't want to say anything I it
was a sub
St sub St I to break attention yeah he's
what
you trying to say I know you had that
chunk I said yeah I did you know how it
is you know I was doing this just please
just don't say anything crazy but I
think through my reaction and then and
how I dealt with the situation and then
also how the way he forgiv me and the
words he said when he forgived me just
showed how much we love each other and
then yeah since then it's just been gang
gang gang gang live yeah um what is your
biggest bag fumble ever I fumbled yeah a
lot we're going what we saying numbers
or not if you say I'll say yeah I don't
mind go on then uh I fumbled 800 bags
Jesus Christ from Texas hold them I
couldn't I can't promote gambling I
can't promote Gambling Man they they
game they offered me 800 bags to go to
Jamaica for two weeks and film content
whil scambling mine was more stupid
because but it's not stupid cuz I
believe in
BSS ra wait actually music yeah music
was even worse two m
oh God 2 m got for the 2 million my
mom's life I got for the 2 million I
Dash that
oh that's the biggest was a single d
That's unheard of to get off that unless
you're C no C probably signed for album
or something he's probably got like 10 m
yeah wow uh and yourself mine wer that
much but mine was dumb well it's not
dumb cuz I proper value like creating
memories with my friends okay I was in I
manager called me last minute said 100
Grand if you come here tomorrow I said
brother tell them keep that 100 bags I
in Bea giv it up and I don't regret one
bit of it but had I been in a different
position what B beef I'm going back say
to my makes sense but I mean all right
man but those two are against man's
morals kind have to makes sense makes
perfect sense who's funnier darkest man
or Harry Panera 3 two one darkest man
dark not even comparable I can't like
comparable no no no but it's not to say
Harry's not funny Dark is just he's in a
different
un he's not with us here you I think
he's made me laugh at every hour of the
day oh wow like maybe every minute I
swear to God must be tough now you don't
live with you now he doesn't live with
me like I'm actually like just walk
around my house just clueless like I'm
devast I missed so much imagine
obviously I'm happy he's
married his wife watching but I I do
miss him very very much uh what's the
best and worst thing about working with
each other yeah I already said he's
annoying as hell but the best thing is
the connection like I think like
genuinely we are the um whenever I work
with Philly is my favorite time ever
like we I think we create the best
content maybe my opinion what do you
think worst thing about me lazy no but
you're not lazy on set oh okay so what's
the what's the best thing I I'll just
keep her a back I don't have a worse the
good thing is just that yeah just lit
when we link up I take back what you can
wait to say I'll take back I take back
but yeah no we don't have to think about
nothing like it's just it's just I was
going to say comes but it just it
it just happen so organically and it's
just so sick I can't lie this it's
actually amazing
this just this
one what I don't know the question can't
remember the question who made the
question does fandom made the question
if a snake bit Philly on a dick would
chunks suck the players in
up an that's facts we had a massive
debate we we actually had that's this
why someone ask that question he said he
honest Philly is
gone to on my life that's what I said
well he's gone you are actually you're
the you're aad what would you do bro for
him I'll Su it I'll suck it twice to
make sure bro he lost his
M you know what is
enough T to make sure it's crazy yeah
I'd go for each
F and you up your lips Bang
no my boy not D my Bo not dying like
that but then do you know what it's it's
so easy to be like say no but that's a
deep asked question nothing about be
mature bro no I'm not I'm being
mature put a glove in your
mouth no what so you you do it for me no
I
wouldn't about I genely wouldn't but I
feel like you got good H I'll just get a
vacuum or
back yeah I'll try get where you getting
a vacuum from bro he's dying on the spot
so you're going to suck out the juices
yeah are your brother facts bro no no no
no wait wait wait wait I I hear you what
happens if you nuts in your mouth no
what do you mean whoa what do you mean
whoo that's usually going to happen no
but one suck won't do that not S one
suck if you do go seek my brother die
he's but no but the point I'm making if
you suck The Poon out then you're deaded
N I spit out a it there spit out like he
knows he knows everything yeah bro we've
had this conversation at he's he's
charging his friendship and he said you
let me die on the spot that's cuz you're
I'm do I can't you're not doing it no
genuinely I won't do it you know you let
him
die that's the easiest question on on
the list you'd have to go easy question
on the list to the point where if I'm
dying in and I'm seeing him trying to
draw for my wood I'll be
like trying to draw for my
wood wait what would you
do I say let me die let me die swear
not me boy I I pushing his head
yeah I'll just say
brother Jam atast know J J do
this me I I I I'll grips his top
just please bro I want to live
please I just say look Broski you got to
go mom's looked after though 20% on my
wage or even turn if you want yeah H you
up my brother love you know I mean tell
tell people I love them yeah Gone Gone
Fair all right next it's a deep question
now um worst interaction with a
fan o uh one of my exes we was walking
down um what's that road there by Knack
town what's that road called Ox Street O
Street yeah I was walking down oxa
street and then there was a fan that saw
me but she's jumped but I'm holding
hands like when I got a girl I don't put
I've never put one of my girls on the
internet but if I'm
I'm saying so we're holding hands but
then when fans come up and jumped on
me she was tiing a buber but where she's
jumped on me what am I going to do
naturally not
to so I'm holding going to grip like in
my hands it's crazy
I'm oh you just Rel cheek to hold Bund
that's bigger than cheeks get out the 's
bum a and it's spilling out it's it's
more than a handful it was wonderful
play like borderline
semi I can't lie my things ariser
quickly as
well say hand on heart no one's ever got
a bone off for hug G oh I have but like
not on regular dular that's standard
different you know do you know how mad
my mind works yeah you see like even if
I know I got a thing coming and I'm
going to slam I'd have a boner just
thinking about no no no I hand on heart
oh my God this happens to me I'll be in
a shower just getting ready the wood
ready you know what I'm saying and
everything's just getting washed and
then in the shower I'm thinking about
the beat and I've Got a Boner Ain
happened to you man that's crazy bro not
since I was like 16 I'm not going to lie
yeah obviously I'm a bit younger
but but yeah no serious matting ariser
quickly say less I don't think I have
from a hug unless unless we're hugging
for time yeah yeah it's a good buy hug
yeah it's a good no but like fan though
like you like her I'm not saying I got
like a random woman or do you get what
I'm saying like I'm talking that you
know what's you know I mean as you just
you're just thinking about what's going
to happen I know you're trying to say
you get what I'm trying to I Charing bro
yeah yeah I know you mean is your
thing's your thing do what you want
jush you do what you want want that's
like remember you man are younger than
yeah I get it more that's what you're
saying 91 make up another two questions
I'm having genu no I got I got two
favorite and least favorite video you
filmed together or no on whatever I I 3
two one
Wales that was in a video that that was
presented what you think that video
didn't come out hopefully then I never
seen it it come up we just didn't
promote it okay
favorite uh big as in big as
in Big Man skull was it it was a
basically a video on my channel it was a
general knowledge quiz and general
knowledge quiz is back in the days when
I used to film at Philly's house or when
he come to my house that was like the
first two years of us being a friend
probably the best times ever because
we'd be sitting down genuinely laughing
crying of tears and then finishing the
video and thinking that was the best
video we ever film so those typ of times
and there there like a a viral viral
clip from them the question was what's
the biggest bone in your body and I said
what big as in what big as in I can't
remember you know what we got to get it
up tap in young Philly strength and
unity yeah that YouTube YouTube that was
hilarious to be fair how sick that clip
is bro my sister sent it to me the other
day crying of laugh saying he's he's
special ated in your body like what like
what though like what like big as in big
as in so big as in heavy or big as in
size cuz this is longer that man's skull
but the skull might be a bit bigger in
terms of strength and
[Laughter]
unity so what I can't say now the part
of the body the bones
in sry sir but I'm not really a bone man
like that I don't you get oh I got it
right no you know I always desend you
like that oh yeah you used desend those
times but yeah I love that video
hilarious it's just it's just me and my
BR sitting down waffling and and we're
getting millions and millions of views
was flipping I'm being real might not be
my favorite but based on the clips that
I've been seeing on Tik Tok that one's
my favorite yours uh off top of my
head I'd say whenever mean you get to
fly out and do stuff man so for proir I
remember those kind of videos always my
favorite fun fact that I don't think
I've ever caught a flight with you for
that
proir yeah I think the only one was
Primark La yeah but that but whenever
how dare I that was my favorite shoot
with you bro he went Super Bowl yeah oh
50 Cent Snoop Dog Eminem I remember the
Vibes last year I think it was was it
last year last year or two years the
year before when Super Bowl happen every
year every yeah every year every f it
might have been it might have been years
ago 2022 F 2021 FB maybe I don't know
but regardless like that was probably my
favorite and Harry was there yeah and
Harry was there as well sick and you got
paid you got paid to watch the Super
Bowl in La come on bro kind of [__]
is this man sickal different life and
then finally what's left on your bucket
list start family man yeah gen think
about that one buff question yeah
serious serious I think about that one
of yeah that's that's I feel like I've
done quite a bit when it comes to career
based stuff obviously I still want to
act um I still want to have a chance
like show showcase other skills um but
the most importantly yeah for me man I
want to I want to I want to start a
family man I want a wife I want kids 27
now you know I mean so getting it
getting it's mad young though I just for
me for me I always feel old old cuz of
the fact I remember when I was 22 you
know what I mean and I think as a 19y
old I thought my had 28 you're written
off that's what I used to think you know
what I
mean the way we've been raised but
that's what I'm trying to say it's
because of the way I've got siblings
that are like 36 37 and I don't think
they're old it's just it's how you feel
day you I me but for me obvious I've
always just wanted to get married a bit
cuz the kids being similar ages I don't
want to be a whole world apart from them
and even our religions are different in
both of us is very important do you get
what I'm saying so yeah I think Bucket
List have a family man yeah get married
and have
kids say I really want that props man so
hard to find
though man can't jump on no Tinder and
you know what my problem is I want the
fairy to too much I want to meet my girl
in the KFC and she's asked for the co
but I've got it and I've got like you
you can have the coast law and through
the coast law I've got the number and G
on our date and the date's amazing like
I want a fairy tale too much that's the
problem you say that before we go yeah I
just want to say I'm proud of you both
might sound weird cuz I a't known you
for a very long time but it's just sick
to see remember we're the minority in
this country you know we're ethnic
minority well done Lads thank you so
still smashing it it's proper sick and
it's even nicer that you're both so
lovely and humble you know what I mean
sometimes success can get get to
people's heads and it's just yeah I'm
glad it's you two in this position and
not someone else for
real same to you man same to you guys
that was very nice chunks and Philly
everybody chunks and Philly guys that
was a banging episode that was a
fantastic episode but yeah man that's we
just remind them of what happened
quickly in this episode so briefly we
took a backseat and allowed these men to
like really
FL wanted but anyway well done you
smashed us
pause
oh my bad my bad myad myad I'm more
worried about him he suck snakewood you
know what I mean I'm more worried for
him now snake wood man careful of you
you know but yeah you man you might
annihilated the game been a sick episode
this is probably one of my favorite my
favores for sure thank you man and yeah
man as always oh plugs you plug how dare
I'm saying though man obviously we got
inspired by some gigs so we decided to
start our own podcast um me and Philly
have I've taken the streets to the
podcast we got the what's it what's this
called the little sh mics you know I
mean we picked it up and decided to
start I think um hopefully there's no
controversy because you know people hate
people that start podcast nowadays have
you guys been seen it oh oh my God they
everyone should ban podcast equipment
but we just it's hope like it's more
light-hearted it's more chilled it's
similar to you guys and yeah we're
starting it so please come over and uh
have a little watch hopefully get the
boys on as well very soon and um yeah
it's just the Avenue where me and Philly
can work with each other again literally
genuinely the only reason we've started
it not too serious we're literally just
waffling having fun and yeah please come
over and watch told you the best
episode's darkest man or Haro yeah H so
you're just B don't fre you're just
baiting everybody you want tell them
exclusives all right we have police we
didn't talk about Gordon Ramsey for
God's sakes right there
SAR all right fine J on it take guys um
I it Jes are you doing the outro on his
thing oh it's a joke you don't want to
never no I think you should do the outro
r no no be be honored if you maned the
outro
wow so we all got to do our names H we
don't foot him yeah well JD and all
these other brands yeah so so I'm going
to go I've been Philly only Js
fuad from the top all right so with that
being said I've been Philly I've been
chunks I've been fad I've been James
make sure you comment like subscribe and
hit the post notification Bell so you
are notified when the boys drop a new
video love and guidance take care
everyone come on
gang
[Music]
that's
that